条的影响会非常非常大，第5条讲的是无论是婚前还是婚后，如果你俩约定啊，比如说他要给你加名字，或者他要把这个房子给你，你俩是有这样的约定的，当时啊，婚前或者婚后他也愿意这么干，他也想给你加名字，他也想给你办过户，但是事实上办不了，比如说还在还贷款，比如说有一定的其他的抵押等等等等，比如说有的房子他可能是回迁房，有的房子可能是现在拿不到房产证的房子，有等等的因素在约束着，或者说在限制着你，就是办不了，加不了名儿，也办不了过户。
在这种情况下，假设有一天你俩要离婚了，当时约定要给你加名的这个房子该怎么办呢？你看啊，法条他是这么说的啊，如果你们双方对这个房子的归属或者这个房子的分割有争议且协商不成的，那都到离婚了，肯定是有争议了，那肯定是协商不成了，那人家肯定是不愿意再给你了，也不愿再给你加名字了，也不愿意给你分钱了，一定是这样对吧？到离婚那会儿了，那肯定是有争议，肯定是协商不成了。好在这种情况下，人民法院根据当事人的诉讼请求，结合给予的目的，综合考虑你们。
结婚多长时间，有没有共同孕育子女以及子女的情况啊？离婚的过错就是谁有过错，谁背叛了家庭，谁家暴谁这乱七八糟的各种的过错，谁对家庭的贡献大小，以及离婚时房屋的市场价格等因素，判决房屋归其中一方所有这个点就非常的关键，判决房屋归其中一方所有就意味着什么可以判解。
原来的房主也可以判给就原来房主答应要给人家加名字，答应要给人家过户的另外一个人就是法院的法官，可以综合考虑以上说的这些情况，把这个房子判给男方，也可以判给女方。
就是如果你婚前或者婚后，你答应你约定好了要给人家加名字，你约定好了要给人家办过户，但实际上还没办过户，按照我们以往的司法经验，按照我们以往打官司的经验，在这种情况下，几乎是不可能判给另一方的，几乎是一定会判给原房主的。
但是现在的这个司法解释，按照他的条文的理解，那么这个条文的理解的话就是可以啊，既可以判给原房主，也可以判给我，答应了要给你办过户，答应了要加你的名字，也可以判给这个人。对于说这个司法解释出台了之后，法官会怎么去理解，怎么去拿这个，掌握这个尺度，会怎么判，我们还得看后续的案例出台了之后，比如最高人民法院，他会出一些指导性的案例，比如各地的，就是比较那个著名的一些高级法院，他也可能会出一些。
案例啊。
答应的是要举证吧，那一定的对吧？约定这个事儿一定是你能拿出证据，要么就是白纸黑字写了的约定，要么就是你有聊天记录，要么就是你有录音，要么就是你有视频，你肯定得证明有这个约定这个事儿的存在，约定这个事儿一定是白纸黑字更靠谱是不是？
你会发现一个什么问题呢？现在这个司法解释化了，房子登记在谁名下这个事儿弱化了赠予这个概念，这个时候他讲的是给予目的，给予目的啊，他不是讲的赠予目的，予和赠予它的区别是什么呢？因为如果说是赠予的话，他就得适用合同法，对吧？合同法里面有一条就是我，我把这个东西想要赠予给你，但是呢，我还没办过户，我把我的房子想要赠与给你，但是我还没有办过户的情况下，我是可以撤销赠与的。
这是赠与合同的这个法律基础对不对，但是他现在这个司法解释里面没有把这个事儿，把他直接写成赠与目的，他写的是给予目的，所以他就想区分赠与的关系，他认为啊，就是婚前婚后要加对方名字，或者要给对方办过户这件事情，不能把他当成赠与那么简单的来看待，因为他是一个以家庭为单位的，综合的，带目的的，带各种各样条件的这样一个加名行为或者过户行为，所以司法解释当中他用的是。
就是要综合去考虑，当初人家为什么要给你加名啊，为什么要给你办过户啊，为什么答应这件事儿啊，应这件事儿的条件是什么呀？嗯，反正目前整体来看就是答应给你加名儿，答应给你办过户，实际上还没办。在这种情况下，法官他综合考量就是你们两口子当时为什么要答应给你啊，为什么要答应给你加名儿，为什么要答应给你办过户，当时是什么样一个情况，然后综合考虑你们结婚的时间，结婚的情况，共同生活的情况，孩子的情况，然后谁的过错，现在这个房子值多少钱，综合考虑这一系列的东西了之后，法官可以判给男的，也可以判给女的，就这房子法官可以判给这个，也可以判给这个。
然后如果法官把房子判给其中一方，那么是否要给对方补偿，这个也是综合去评判，就是给是否要给补偿，给多少补偿，按照刚刚讲的那个一系列的东西去评判，就这么个情况，听完这一条了，大家会有什么感受？就是你俩约定好了，要给你加名，要给你办过户，实际上又没办成，下一款的这个司法解释也挺炸裂的，这个司法解释讲的是什么呢？就是婚前或者婚后。
一方已经给对方加名了，甚至已经把房子过户给对方了，那这种情况下啊，就是已经加名了，已经把房子过户给对方了，这个以前在我们的认知水平里面的话，这事儿就是一种物权的行为啊，它是一个影响非常重的行为，你给人家都已经把名儿登记上了，都已经把房子都已经过户给人家了，这是一件对大家来说的话，都是一件非常严肃的事情。
但是这一条的司法解释说，如果有一天你俩要离婚又分割，肯定商量不了嘛，协商不成的情况下，如果法院来判的话，法院就会去考察什么因素呢？结婚时间长短，给予方有没有大过错，如果结婚时间短，给予方没有重大过错，那么法官还有一项权利，就是直接把这个房子判回给予方，这个对于哪些人是一个晴天霹雳啊，对于那些不管是男女啊，想要通过婚姻去。
呃，捞人家的房产，想要通过婚姻去把人家的房产变成自己的，对这些人就是致命的一击，这个司法解释，他打击的就是这些人，打击的就是那些结婚的时候目的不单纯，目的就是为了说，哎，他给我加了名了之后，我就跟他要闹分手，当然不管男女啊，男女都有这样的啊，我理姐，我现在不能够恶意的去揣测，不能把所有的恶意的东西都放到女生身上，就有的男的也有这样的啊，我可能入赘，哎，我入赘的条件是什么？入赘的条件就是你给我加名的，生活中就是江浙沪的独生女有好多都是招上门女婿，招上门女婿也是啊，我上来就要求你加我名儿，我就可以上门女婿，上门女婿了之后我拜年我就撤了。
是吧？这个司法解释他打击的就是这种人，无论男女，你想要通过短暂的婚姻去获取别人家的财产、房产的利益，这个法官是可以，因为你们结婚时间短，且给予方没有重大过错的情况下，那么人民法院是可以根据当事人的诉讼请求判决这个房屋。
归给予者所有，就是相当于把这个房子再判回去啊，然后要不要给对方补偿，那么这个时候就要看看你们当时给予的目的，要综合考虑你们有没有共同生活，共同生活多久，以及共同孕育子女的情况，离婚的过错是谁，对家庭的贡献大小，以及离婚时房屋的市场价格等因素，再来确定要不要给另一方补偿，以及给多少钱的补偿。这个说明白了吗？结婚时间长短的标准是什么？没有一个具体的这样一个标准，以我们以往的工作经验来看，那不到2年的都算短，我这么一说是不是？有些人说啊，那我就努努力，撑到两年，不要这么搞，姐妹们啊，兄弟们不要这么想问题好吗？我知道我这样一说的话，肯定会有人说，那我就努努力，我就撑到两年，不要这么搞，不要这么想问题啊，因为法官他最终还会结合其他因素，他不光是结合结婚时间这个因素，他还得结合你俩有没有实际在一起共同生活，还会结合你俩有没有生孩子，还会结合很多因素的，刚刚有个朋友说流过产这个因素重要吗？这个因素重要就是共同孕育子女，这里的共同孕育子女其实也包含着比如说你有过流产的经历，有过引产。
的经历，这些都会考量在里面，刚刚有朋友问得了尖锐失疣呢，这个还不好说，你很难去证明他是因为什么原因得了尖锐失优，得尖锐失疣，它是一个结果，在我们的婚姻家庭的这个司法解释或者说法条里面关注的是什么，关注的是行为本身，就如果说他是因为长期PC。
或者他是因为长期的有不忠于夫妻的行为，那他得了这个尖锐失疣的话，你得结合这些证据，你得首先得证明他长期PC，多次PC，你得证明他有各种不正当的男女关系或者男男关系，你得证明到这个程度了之后，在婚姻关系当中才能够把他当成一个保护你的这样一个证据去使用，但你光是说他得得了尖锐是疣，但是你无法证明他是因为什么原因得了这个尖锐使疣，有可能是因为别的情况下传染的呢，就是这么个情况啊，这条大家都听明白了吗？就是无论是婚前还是婚后，对方已经给你加了名字，或者对方已经把房子过户给你了，但如果说你们结婚时间短，且人家给予方没有重大过错的情况下，这个房子还是有可能判回去归给予方所有，然后是否要给你补偿？
以及给多少补偿，取决于当时给予的目的是什么，你们夫妻呃，结婚时存续时间呃，情况，然后有没有共同孕育子女啊，谁的过错要离婚呀，然后嗯，房屋现在的市场价值啊，要综合这些去考量要不要给你补偿，以及给你多少补偿这么个情况，其实我觉得这事儿啊，我跟大家就聊一聊我的担忧好不好，就有没有这种可能啊，有的男孩儿，比如说他特别喜欢一个女女孩儿女神嘛啊，他觉得能得到这个女神的话，哪怕得到他半年，他也觉得他愿意付出很多的代价，那有没有这种可能？
他上来就说我把房子过户给你，然后我跟你结婚，结婚了之后半年我就提离婚，有没有这种可能，对不起，我会讲我比较坏，我就心眼儿坏，我就是个坏人，我感觉是有这种可能的，所以各位女神啊，各位女孩子，你不要因为谁给你加名字去结婚，不要因为谁给你办房产证过户去结婚，不要因为这个原因结婚，是因为你真的考察他这个人，你觉得他。
善良，然后真心实意的对你好，有责任心，嗯，有耐心，情绪也很好，工作也很勤恳，然后有同理心，有共情心，你因为这些原因去结婚，不要因为说谁给你办了过户你去结婚，谁给你加了名你去结婚啊，大多数肯定是正常人，我说的就是这个意思，就是龙飞姐，我就是鼓励大家不要看，不要因为这个原因去结婚，如果你光是因为人家给你一套房子结婚，那人家可能人家就想跟你过半年，人家就想跟你过一年，人家过半年，过一年了之后，人家起诉去离婚的话，这个房子还得退给他，其中还有一条啊，对于那个给予方非常友好的一条，予方如果你把这个房子已经给对方了，已经办过户了，但是后来你发现你受到了欺诈，或者说你是被胁迫这么干的啊？
或者你的近亲属的权益就是遭到了对方的严重侵害。
或者说你这方出现了很重大的问题，比如说嗯，需要做一个很严重的手术，需要30万，但是对方收到你的房对吧，或者你怎么怎么样了之后，他拒绝给你出这个钱，那么你都可以去撤销这个给予行为，这个我觉得是合情合理的啊，我给大家讲一个最极端的例子好不好？比如说一个男同学，嗯，他把房子过户给女生，为什么呢？啊，因为女生给他生孩子嘛，他觉得女生也挺辛苦的啊，挺不容易的，给他生了孩子，所以就把这个房子已经过户给女生了，嗯。
他们俩分手了之后呢，他又发现一个很重大的问题，什么问题？
孩子不是他亲生的，就他当初之所以把这个房产过户给女方，就是因为就是因为女方给他生了孩子，他觉得女方不容易啊，后来又发现这孩子不是亲生的，那他可不可以撤销这个赠与行为呢？那我个人啊，我个人的判断是于情于理于法，他都有撤销这个赠与行为的依据啊，是不是再有一个，就比方说，呃，把房子已经过户给对方了，但是我这头可能出现一点状况，比如说身体上，我可能需要30万来治病，来救命，但是你那头呢？
你不愿意啊，对吧，我俩是夫妻关系啊，我把房子过户给你了，你那头不愿意出钱，那我可不可以撤销这个给予的行为，撤销这个过户的行为可以的。
这个大家都能理解啊，就是说我把这个房子虽然说已经给你了，最后我发现你在欺诈我，你胁迫我，或者你严重侵害我的近亲属的合法权益，或者你对我有抚养的义务，但是你不履行，你不照顾我，我病了你不照顾我，我都住院了，你不给我钱去交医药费，在这种情况下，我是可以请求人民法院去撤销那个给予行为的。好了，那么这一条就是关于呃，婚前或者婚后加名字也好，过户房产也好，关于这一条是不是就跟大家讲明白了呀？
这套听明白了啊。